i don't care what your religious beliefs
are anything if you have a dick you need
to shut the [ __ ] up on this one
seriously
this is
theirs the right to choose is their
unequivocal right not only do i believe
they have the right to choose i believe
that they shouldn't have to consult
anybody
except for a physician
about how
they exercise that right
gentlemen that is fair
and ladies
to be fair to us
i also believe if you decide to have the
baby
a man should not have to pay
that's fair
if you can kill this [ __ ] i can
at least abandon them
it's my money my choice
i don't mean any of this stuff i'm just
saying words in a certain order to
elicit laughter people like try to
figure me out do my act it's all jokes i
told an abortion joke recently and a
woman approached me she was like hey
that's very insensitive i've had an
abortion you shouldn't tell jokes like
that i was like whoa hey sorry i just
told a joke i think what you did was
much worse
but you know
either way i'll see at home later honey
and again all jokes i love abortions i
paid for two last week i'm a fan right
you remember come on
it's all jokes friend of mine she works
at planned parenthood she loves that
joke and i was like i might have to get
rid of it people don't like it she's
like no no you got to keep it i was like
i might get rid of she's like no no you
got to keep but i was like oh my god
it's like no you got to kill him
i was like don't tell me to do my body
of work she's like every joke's a
miracle
but i don't want to upset anybody you
know
oh geez
i just want to let you all know right
now ladies uh i am with you i think is
your body your choice i agree with you
on that
i agree with you when you say that men
should have no say in the decisions you
make with your bodies those are your
decisions to make and yours alone and i
feel that way because uh at the end of
the day when we all go up to heaven and
god's like why are we all killing babies
we're gonna be like y'all
i think they were very clear whose
decision this was guy
looks like you need to pay for your sins
babe
even though i paid for your sins
come on y'all chivalry ain't dead to
that baby as you know the rules
[ __ ]
all right i got some momentum let's
break out the abortion jokes so
if there was ever a time
my friend just had one her boyfriend
didn't contribute to the cost which i
thought was not cool you know
she's going through yeah that's not a
very noble stance i don't think
that is how low the bar is i'm like i
should pay a little bit for the abortion
of women like he's a hero he really is
no even the most pro-life person i
talked to was like wow chivalry is dead
that was the baby's name chivalry and
you know
dad
i'm just saying
that one that one's not for everybody
that should yeah
i did that joke the other night somebody
yelled out boo
i thought it was a baby's ghost but you
know
i'm just
now
i don't want to divide the room um but
i'm pro-choice i don't think it's
anything with me or any other man what a
woman does with her body right but on
the uh
thank you on the on the flip side that
there are people who are anti-abortion i
don't mean people who wouldn't have it
for themselves that's choice i mean i
don't want anyone to have it and of
those there's a small percentage that
are really militant and of those there
are small percentages that are [ __ ]
me there's there's ones in america that
are like terrorists they bomb abortion
clinics they put fetuses through your
door and they've got this propaganda
machine there's something else liberals
uh they're aborting babies at nine
months pulling them out of the vagina
and liquidizing them like crazy
conspiracy theory right and now they've
got the internet so they've got like
fonts and memes it's like science to
them right and this thing goes round
right you've probably seen it but uh it
goes
i've heard different derivations of it
like this was a real lecture or this was
a real questionnaire right it's nonsense
it's all made up right it goes like it
goes
a woman is pregnant she already has five
children two are deaf two are blind one
is mentally [ __ ]
she has syphilis should she have the
baby no question mark well done you just
killed beethoven
that makes no [ __ ] sense
at all okay okay keep it fair let's do
the opposing so okay there's another
woman
she's pregnant two children great
hearing great eyesight really smart she
hasn't got syphilis should she have the
baby yes question mark well done you
just gave birth to hitler
my mom said four kids you can tell that
she loves us all the same but after the
first two she kind of stopped caring
she'll always go about she was blessed
with me
then she was gifted with my sister
then she had my brother
and she'll always remember the day that
she was diagnosed with the other one
we were all intentional though uh which
is good my mom's
has a very healthy eyelid to
contraception which is great because her
sister is anti-abortion which is a cruel
nickname but she's had five
i'm as surprised as you want that they
let me do that joke i
got a lot of freedom in america man for
instance abortion's legal it's beautiful
that abortion is legal man yes
beautiful
i love going to abortion rallies to pick
up women
because you know that [ __ ]
you ain't gonna find a bunch of virgins
at the abortion rally
you might even see some clear hills
oh the abortion issue man it's a woman's
issue a woman get pregnant she'll want
to hear [ __ ] from the man [ __ ] you i
don't need you [ __ ] you unless she
decides to have the baby then she's like
where am i checking
that's right when a woman gets pregnant
it's a choice between the woman
and her girlfriends
a woman get pregnant her and her
girlfriends get together and they have a
little abortion tribunal
and they vote on the baby like it's
survivor
and each girlfriend puts in her two
cents and one girlfriend goes child you
should have that baby that man got some
good hair it's wavy it's waving
and the other girlfriend goes child why
are we even talking about this ain't we
supposed to go to cancun next week get
rid of that baby
and that's how life is decided in
america
now fellas
if you get a woman pregnant you're only
allowed to say two things two things and
guess what fellas you can't even suggest
abortion if you say uh you [ __ ] up
you can't even suggest abortion and
guess what guys you don't want to
suggest abortion because if you suggest
abortion and then she has the baby when
that kid's about five six years old he
gonna be cursing your ass out you go hey
what's up little man how you doing man
i'm alive just how the [ __ ] i'm doing
you want to be dead huh [ __ ]
i'm alive [ __ ] i shall bust a
cap in your ass
you don't need that drama
so do not suggest abortion now fellas
if you get a woman pregnant
you only got two things to say
two ways to try it out now the first
thing you can say is wow i can't believe
you're pregnant i'm so happy i can't
wait for you to have this baby i love
you so much
that's cool
now if you don't want to say that you
got one more
choice
a woman walks in the room
tells you that she's praying you look
her dead in the eye and you say
so what you gonna do
[Applause]
let's talk abortion
there you go everybody has an opinion
it's my buddy it's my right well then
[ __ ] drive to arkansas [ __ ] right
everybody has an opinion
as do i and i apologize that you're
going to have to listen to mine
because
i'm going to tell you right now i have a
really weird
i have a really weird take on abortion
i'm going to tell you that right from
the get-go okay i'm 100 pro-choice
always happened it's a ladies i said it
was weird but the love of god
stop getting in the trunk in the car
wait to the end
you're supposed to vent me first
[ __ ] feed out the sunroof
i said i had a weird day
pro-choice always makes sense to me
because i don't like people telling me
what to do and i was just like it's your
body who the [ __ ] am i to tell you what
to do with your body so that always made
sense all right however
i still think you're killing a baby
see
that's where it gets weird
like i sit on the fence and the whole
thing makes sense to me whatever
anybody's saying like don't tell me what
to do it's my body my choice that's
right man she's right leaving the hell
alone oh you're killing the baby well i
mean there is that
hell
i mean you know we're going to be honest
that is the whole purpose of the
procedure
you know you're not going in there
because you got an earring
going in there because you're like i got
a baby in me get the [ __ ] out of here
right you walk in with the baby you come
out without one what happened to the
baby right
something [ __ ] happened so
pro-choice people like well it's not a
life yet it's not a baby yet if you
don't know what they say before you do
the first thursday or the last tuesday
you spin around one time
they dance between the rape trucks
it's not a baby yet that's what they say
which may or may not be true i don't
know i'm not a doctor but i'll tell you
my gut tells me that doesn't make sense
it's not a baby yet that would be like
if i was making a cake and i poured some
batter in a pan and i put it in the oven
and then five minutes later you came by
and you grabbed the pan you threw it
across the floor
and what the [ __ ] are you throwing my
birthday cake
and then you're like well that wasn't a
cake yet
it's like well it would have been
if you didn't do what you just did there
would have been a cake in 50 minutes
something happened to that k.q cake
murder son of a [ __ ]
right
now
before all you pro-life people get
excited i think it's great you're
killing your babies
it's fantastic
help mother nature out there's too many
of us
it's been 130 degrees out
animals are going extinct
there's plastic in the [ __ ] ocean
we don't need
any more [ __ ] people and especially
you know if you're honest with yourself
have you done anything great with your
life
is the person you're banging doing
anything great
the answer to both of those questions is
no what are the odds you're gonna make a
great person
i'm not saying you're gonna make a bad
person you're just gonna make another
person that doesn't go when the light
turns green because you're staring at
their [ __ ] phone
i don't think women
should be they don't have a choice it's
not i don't believe after they're
pregnant there's one excuse rape other
than that they don't it's not their body
no more
there's nobody this not your body once
you're
it doesn't belong to you because god
didn't ask you if you if you wanted a
choice to be able to make babies and it
didn't he didn't ask as if if men wanted
a choice to be able to have sperm we
just happen to be able to do it but the
the result is not your body the result
i'm telling the result is the baby's
body it's the baby's body it's not your
body after you're pregnant